[Musik]
die lage ist heute eine grundlegend
andere
und deshalb
müssen wir angesichts der jüngsten
entwicklung diese lage auch neu bewerten
übrigens auch im hinblick auf aus dem 2
ich habe das
bundeswirtschaftsministerium heute
gebeten den bestehenden bericht zur
analyse der versorgungssicherheit bei
der bundesnetzagentur zurückzuziehen und
ohne diese zertifizierung kann aus dem
zwei ja nicht in betrieb gehen
deutschland stockt nord stream 2 am tag
eins nach der rede von wladimir putin
die viele inzwischen als zeitenwende
sehen damit herzlich willkommen zu einem
zdf spezial die nachfolgenden sendungen
verschieben sich um zirka 20 minuten
als klaren bruch des völkerrechts
bezeichnet deutschland die ankündigung
moskaus die separatisten gebiete
anzuerkennen und truppen in die ost
ukraine zu schütten benötigt der westen
reagiert entsetzt verhängt sanktionen
über putins folgenschweren auftritt der
einheit
um europas nachkriegsordnung endgültig
zu zerlegen muss er sich nicht einmal
gerade hinsetzen lässig und gehässig am
schreibtisch spricht der kreml chef der
ukraine kurzerhand das recht auf
selbstbestimmung ab weil sie im grunde
eine rein russische erfindung sein
sie hat gar keine eigenen staatliche
tradition sondern hat immer nur andere
kopiert und die bedürfnisse einer macht
elite befriedigt und zwar über die köpfe
des volkes hinweg
dafür kann er sich des jubels seiner
fans in der betroffenen region sicher
sein
ein paar dutzend feierten bei
minusgraden im dom bass die putin
erklärung unverzüglich mit krimsekt und
mit feuerwerk
in den so genannten volksrepublik
herrschen seit 2014 die moskautreuen
separatisten und die haben nun
oberwasser
ich könnte heulen vor glück wir haben so
lange darauf gewartet russland ist in
unserem herzen ich und meine ganze
familie wir sind nämlich russische
staatsbürger
die anführer des jubel kurs hatten sich
für diese offenbar lange geplante
charade nach moskau begeben um den kreml
chef um hilfe zu bitten
[Musik]
lieber wladimir wladimirowitsch um ein
massensterben von russischen
staatsbürgern zu verhindern bitte ich
sie um die anerkennung der volksrepublik
lugansk
und wir möchten sie auf bitten ein
freundschafts- und verteidigungsabkommen
mit der volksrepublik don jetzt zu
schließen
und schon sitzen die beiden
selbsternannten volksvertreter ein
ehemaliger zollfahnder und ein früherer
finanzjongleur im festsaal des kreml um
mit wladimir wladimirowitsch das
gewünschte dokument zu unterzeichnen
wobei putin gleich auch noch die
entsendung von truppen verfügt
wie sich zeigte hat selbst die moskauer
macht elite seine schachzüge noch nicht
ganz verstanden er unterstütze die
aufnahme der gebiete in die russische
föderation stottert der spionage chef
woraufhin putin ihn rüffelt darum geht
es doch hier gar nicht wir sprechen über
ihre unabhängigkeit
ja genau unzweideutig dagegen die
reaktion aus kiew nur präsident selensky
seine landsleute zur besonnenheit mahnte
wir gehen unbeirrt weiter auf unserem
weg und fürchten nichts und niemanden
die zufalls umfrage im nächtlichen kiew
bringt dann auch trotzige aber vor allem
kühle reaktionen
sollen sie doch anerkennen was sie
wollen das kann uns doch egal sein
der westen muss uns nun bei stehen
allein können wir das problem mit den
volks republiken nicht lösen
mit ölfässern und europaflagge zog dann
heute ein grüppchen demonstranten vor
der russischen botschaft in kiew auf die
ihrem ärger über putin luft machten
während dieser in moskau präsident
alijew aus baku zum tischgespräch bad
und versicherte russland plane durchaus
nicht sein altes reich wieder
herzustellen sondern akzeptiere die
geopolitische realität
die zahl derer die solche aussagen
glauben dürfte seit gestern wieder etwas
kleiner geworden sein
in paris gab es heute eine
dringlichkeitssitzung der
eu-außenminister dort begrüße ich
annalena baerbock guten abend
sehr guten abend bauwerk wie überrascht
waren denn sie und ihre kollegen vom
vorgehen putins der die diplomatie
versuche ja auch von deutschland so ins
leere laufen lassen
überrascht nicht aber massiv enttäuscht
wir haben uns ja auf unterschiedliche
szenarien vorbereitet wir haben immer
wieder deutlich gemacht in den letzten
tagen zuletzt auch noch mal auf der
münchner sicherheitskonferenz am
wochenende dass wir alles dafür tun
gemeinsam in frieden in europa zu leben
und das der russische präsident jetzt
entschieden hat genau das gegenteil zu
tun nämlich mit einem einmarsch das ist
es ja die faktisch indem er die
republiken anerkannt hat die
souveränität der ukraine zu brechen und
damit auch die friedens grundordnung in
europa zu brechen das ist wirklich
erschütternd wir haben von
unterschiedlichen szenarien gesprochen
worauf stellen sie sich denn nun ein was
halten sie für wahrscheinlich
wir sehen dass es offensichtlich einem
der skripte folgt die vorher auch im
raum gestanden haben dass man erst
versucht durch falschinformationen es
gab ja vor einigen tagen die
behauptungen das gäbe angriffe von der
ukraine die es nicht gegeben hat dass
wir diesen falschbehauptungen versucht
worden ist ein vorwand zu finden weil
man militärisch ag jetzt als das dann
nicht aufgegangen ist hat man sich jetzt
offensichtlich dafür entschieden dass
man offen mit dem minsker abkommen was
selber von russischer seite
unterschrieben worden war bricht damit
offenen völkerrechts bruche begeht um
auf dieser grundlage jetzt das nächste
szenario vorzubereiten das wurde in den
letzten stunden jahr deutlich dass man
jetzt sagt man müsste angeblich zum
schutz der bevölkerung in die ost
ukraine
eindringen vordringen und damit de facto
dann militärische präsenz sein wir haben
heute hier deutlich gemacht dass wir
geschlossen stehen nicht nur als
europäerinnen und europäer nicht nur als
transatlantische partner sondern ich
habe auch zu einer sondersitzung
beziehungsweise sonder telefonate der g7
außenminister einberufen wo auch japan
mit dabei ist die deutlich gemacht haben
wir akzeptieren diesen bruch des
internationalen rechts nicht wir hatten
hier durch zufall eigentlich eine tagung
mit den südostasiatischen
partnern auch da gab es ganz ganz klare
unterstützung dieser völker rechtsbruch
ist nicht hinzunehmen und deswegen
bereiten wir jetzt auch eine klare
antwort darauf vor mit einem harten
sanktionspaket was ein erster schritt
für diese situation ist und wir werden
uns die nächsten tage weiter anschauen
ob weitere maßnahmen folgen müssen was
ist denn das worst case szenario das
schlimmstmögliche fall der eintreten
könnte jetzt demnächst
in dieser situation tun wir weiterhin
alles dafür dass es zu keiner weiteren
aggressionen kommt wie gesagt dass es
steht im raum dass es jetzt doch
truppenbewegungen gibt es sind ja die
truppen bereits an der grenze wir machen
deutlich wir werden das nicht hinnehmen
das hat massive wirtschaftliche
finanzielle und erst recht politische
konsequenzen für russland
über worst-case-szenarien möchte ich an
dieser stelle jetzt nicht weiter
sprechen die ukraine ist ein souveränes
land die menschen haben ein recht darauf
in frieden zu leben weitere militärische
maßnahmen und schritte sei es in der ost
ukraine oder eben darüber hinaus was ja
weiteres szenario während das ist nicht
akzeptabel und die internationale
gemeinschaft deswegen auch so wichtig
dass die vereinten nationen sich damit
beschäftigen müssen darauf eine antwort
geben
der ukrainische botschafter in
deutschland spricht von einer
kriegserklärung putins nicht nur an die
ukraine sehen sie das auch so
wenn man die rede des präsidenten
gestern gehört hat dann muss man nicht
nur sagen dass es unglaublich war
sondern eigentlich desaströses wird die
existenz der ukraine in frage gestellt
umgangssprachlich kann man da vielleicht
kriegserklärung zu sagen rechtlich ist
es das nicht aber man hat die ukraine
angegriffen indem man diese republiken
anerkannt hat indem man jetzt deutlich
macht man werde die republiken sichern
auch sichern mit militär und darauf
müssen wir jetzt eine ganz klare antwort
geben vielen dank annalena baerbock
dankeschön
ja das gespräch haben wir vor dem
rückflug von außenministerin baerbock
aufgezeichnet wie geht es jetzt weiter
wie bei putin gehen das ist die große
frage manuela konrad mit möglichen
szenarien
was will wladimir putin in der ukraine
experten sprechen von mehreren szenarien
szenario 1 laut informationen der
geheimdienste sommer cyberangriffen ein
angriff auf die hauptstadt kiew erfolgen
und eine land invasion das diene vor
allem dazu die regierung in kiew zu
stürzen um eine kreml treue
marionettenregierung einzusetzen die
folgen wären viele zivile opfer
fluchtbewegungen
widerstandskämpfer die variante gilt als
eher unwahrscheinlich
innenpolitisch für putin auch in
russland schwer vermittelbar
szenario 2 er wahrscheinlich der
einmarsch in die selbsternannten
volksrepublik jetzt um lohans bis hin zu
den im moment noch von ukrainischen
truppen gehaltenen gebieten im don was
das ziel den gesamten don boscos isches
staatsgebiet integrieren zudem wird
spekuliert dass russland interesse an
einer landverbindung über mario pohl auf
die krim hat um sie dauerhaft zu
versorgen
laut experten könnte putin militärbasen
im donbass einrichten ukrainische und
russische truppen würden sich dann
gegenüber stehen und die
zivilbevölkerung dort wird weiter opfer
möglicher kämpfe werden eine humanitäre
katastrophe würde sich zuspitzen
russland hat die ukraine wie einst
georgien 2008 in einen konflikt
verwickelt der eine nahaufnahme auf
lange sicht unwahrscheinlich macht
gleichzeitig orientiert sich die ukraine
immer stärker zum westen und zur eu
putin will das verhindern politisch
mitbestimmen der ukraine mehr macht
einfluss in osteuropa und seine größte
forderung an den westen nato-truppen
zurückdrängen russland hat wirklich wenn
sie wollen schon vor langer zeit
beschlossen
den westen zurückzudrängen ich sagen
industrie zu erklären aber massiv zurück
zu drängen das ist das eigentliche ziel
des cookie
zurückdrängen eine sorge russland könnte
die schmale nato-land verbindung
zwischen der exklave kaliningrad und
belarus zu den baltischen staaten kappen
estland lettland und litauen wären dann
von der hilfe auf dem landweg
abgeschnitten
bei mir im studio ist jetzt der
ehemalige nato-general egon ramms guten
abend
lasst uns das ganze mal militärisch
betrachten welches szenario halten sie
denn als das wahrscheinlichste
also wenn ich die aussagen von putin vom
gestrigen tag nehmen wenn ich die
anerkenntnis erklärung für die beiden ob
laste nehme dann gehe ich davon aus
dass putin mit hilfe des russischen
militärs versuchen wird die oberste
komplett in die hand zu bekommen und
dann wird er möglicherweise verharren
also nicht weiter nach westen vordringen
vielleicht doch noch alle möglichkeiten
sieht noch eine möglichkeit die
landbrücke richtung krim zu schließen
über mario pohl das würden die ersten
ziele sondern alles weitere muss man
sehen wie es sich entwickelt die nato
selbst wird ja nicht in der ukraine
kämpfen so viel steht fest aber kann
sich denn die ukraine überhaupt gegen so
eine übermächtige armee wieder
russischen verteidigen also ich
beurteile das im augenblick so dass die
ukrainische armee mit rund 200.000
soldaten gegenüber der russischen armee
russischen streitkräften in der nähe der
ukraine durchaus die möglichkeit
möglichkeit hat die ukrainische armee
hat sich soll 2014 an aktionen der krim
deutlich verändert sie hat modernisierte
waffensysteme keine neuen und vor allen
dingen zeugen die soldaten eine hohe
moral eine hohe kampfkraft schauen wir
dass das kräfteverhältnis mal konkret an
auf einer grafik oder hana hat sich
einen überblick verschafft
russland hat nach westlichen schätzungen
rund
150.000 soldaten an der grenze zur
ukraine zusammengezogen hinzu kommen
etwa 40.000 kämpfer der separatisten in
den selbst ernannten volksrepublik in
donetsk und lohans die ukraine verfügt
landesweit über gut 200.000 aktive
soldaten multi nationale verbände der
nato verstärken die baltischen staaten
und polen mit mehr als 5000 zusätzlichen
soldaten
außerdem haben die usa und
großbritannien im rahmen von bilateralen
vereinbarungen und 9000 weitere soldaten
nach polen verlegt für das nato mitglied
rumänien ist eine verstärkung von etwa
2000 mann geplant und auch in bulgarien
ungarn und der slowakei will das
verteidigungsbündnis weitere truppen
stationieren
die nato genügend vorbereitet auf
russlands aggressionspolitik also zahl
ist ja die nato nicht angegriffen also
wir haben keinen verlust von partituren
zu fürchten das heißt es geht für die
nato im raum gibt darum zu demonstrieren
dass sie bereit ist nato territorium
wurde das gebiet unsere bündnispartner
zu verteidigen wenn es denn dafür bedarf
gibt bei dem was wir jetzt in dieser
grafik an truppenbewegungen gesehen
haben ist die very high eines joint task
force noch nicht mit dabei diese könnte
man in diese bilanz auch noch mit
einführenden die könnte relativ schnell
in marsch gesetzt werden um an einer
beliebigen stelle und einer notwendigen
stelle dann nochmal zu verstärken
das ist seit 2016 eine task force die
jedes jahr rotiert mit anderen länder
besitzt wird im jahr 2009 10 war
deutschland die
diese taskforce geführt im zweiten jahr
2023 wieder das sind verschiedene
truppenkontingente aus verschiedenen
nato staaten
jeweils in brigade stärke und erzählt
jeweils die brigade mit dazu die im jahr
vorher diese rolle gespielt hat um gegen
ja nachher die rolle spielen wird so
dass sie im prinzip auf die stärke mehr
als eine division allein war
landstreitkräften kommen da gehört noch
ein luftwaffen anteil und marina und
auch mit dazu ihrer meinung nach was
kann was sollte der westen jetzt noch
tun aber der westen kann jetzt nur
versuchen die geschlossenheit die bisher
gezeigt worden ist das gilt für nato und
eu
gemeinsam mit den amerikanern weiter zu
halten und zu zeigen und wirklich
deutlich zu machen dass das was gestern
mit einem perfekten drehbuch in russland
entschieden und angeschoben worden ist
nicht die letzte lösung sein kann und
dass es vor allen dingen wenn man diese
dinge nimmt nicht weitergehen kann aus
drehbuch darf nicht fortgesetzt werden
vielen dank egon ramms die stehen ja
gleich noch der zdf heute live
zuschauerfragen zur verfügung vielen
dank
eine waffenlieferung an die ukraine hat
deutschland immer ausgeschlossen die
drohen im falle in der invasion waren
immer sanktionen und heute hat olaf
scholz ja auch reagiert die umstrittene
erdgaspipeline aus dem 2 auf eis gelegt
deutschland müsse sich weniger abhängig
machen von russischen energielieferungen
so der welt wie groß die abhängigkeit
bisher ist sein hang
die ukraine krise könnte ein problem
auch für die deutsche energieversorgung
werden denn russland ist deutschlands
wichtigster energielieferant eine
gegenseitige abhängigkeit
wir haben eine sehr enge partnerschaft
mit russland in energiefragen also
sowohl im bereich kohle als auch erdgas
rund 55 prozent unserer gasimporte
kommen aus russland und das obwohl es
schon nach der annexion der krim 2014
aus berlin hieß dass es eine durchaus
neue betrachtung der gesamten
energiepolitik geben wird doch die
beziehungen wurden ihr enger auf die
ostsee pipeline nord stream folgten nord
stream zwei die es auf eis liegt trotz
aller spannungen milliarden euro fließen
jedes jahr in richtung moskau in
russland ist auch unser bedeutendes der
lieferant von rohöl mit knapp 34 prozent
und
steinkohle und nur schwer zu ersetzen
beispiel gas zwar heißt es von der
europäischen union man könne auch ohne
russisches gas auskommen doch wieder
norwegen noch die niederlande als
wichtige gaslieferanten könnten die
lücke füllen bleiben die usa schiffe mit
flüssiggas steuern europa bereits an der
aufwand ist aber groß und gut
vorbereitet sind wir nicht es sind jetzt
schon an einigen flüssiggas terminals an
der kapazitätsgrenze
insofern ist da nicht mehr so viel raum
nach oben und das würde dann natürlich
aber auch bedeuten dass die preise noch
weiter nach oben gehen würden
zuverlässige energie aus russland gegen
harte euros aus deutschland für beide
wäre ein ende dieser partnerschaft
schmerzhaft und teuer
man zugeschaltet ist jetzt die russland
expertin sarah packung verpackung
deutschland europa haben heute
sanktionen beschlossen weitere angedroht
wie sehr wird das denn wladimir putin
beeindrucken
die eu vor einigen in zusammenarbeit mit
usa durchaus in der lage die russische
wirtschaft massiv schaden vor allen
dingen mit sanktionen gegen russische
finanzinstitutionen aber beispielsweise
auch mit handelsembargos un sanktionen
die griechische staatsschulden wie groß
die auswirkungen genau sein werden hängt
jetzt davon ab wie die sanktion genau
ausgestaltet werden wir haben noch keine
negativen details dafür erscheint mir
doch bis jetzt so zu sein dass die eu
noch nicht direkt das ganz große besteck
auspackt sondern möglicherweise damit
wartet bis russland auch in den rest der
ukraine vordringen könnte ja was glauben
sie denn wie wird es weitergehen was
dass putins plan
mit der anerkennung der beiden
separatistischen republiken hat putin de
facto dass minsk abkommen zerstört oder
zu ende gebracht dh er braucht jetzt ein
anderes mittel um aufklärung auf die
ukraine einfluss auszuüben und das
risiko dass er das mit militärischen
mitteln auch durch ein weiteres
vordringen in die noch von der
ukrainischen regierung kontrollierten
gebiete machen wird ist aus meiner sicht
aktuell wirklich sehr hoch und was kann
der besten denn jetzt überhaupt noch tun
im moment bleibt der eindruck putin
agiert die welt reagiert und ist vor
allem eins geschockt
also angesichts des nur dass wir in den
letzten zwei tagen in den räten putins
gesehen haben auch in sonstigen
verhalten müssen fürchten dass der
einfluss des westens nicht mehr
sonderlich groß ist was wir tun können
dass zum einen die eigene abschreckung
stärken und zum anderen nimmt auch die
ukraine treff finanziell zu unterstützen
um hier möglichst die kosten für eine
russische invasion hochzutreiben vielen
dank für diese einschätzung sarah
packung
ja das war unser zdf spezial zu den
einschneidenden ereignissen in russland
und der ukraine der die gesamte
europäische sicherheitsarchitektur ins
wanken bringt mehr informationen später
im heute journal ein interview mit
bundeskanzler urlaubs einen schönen
abend noch
[Musik]